hello what's up charger
gamer
hello can you GP my bro hey alas
alas hello bro
Alias
elas damn
it yeah I'm good I'm
good third stream already
yeah we went from no streams for almost
half a year to two a
week which you know it's kind of because
I'm making up for the lack of videos
since I'm working on a very big one
right now but yeah
yeah yeah I'm doing good been taking it
easy
today actually where are we going oh
joyon drift we should probably do the
Zora Quest this time because we already
did the Goron one last
time on a different stream in an age
long
forgotten what do you think the new the
next Zelda game will be
uh something completely different
probably I think they're they're going
to move into a different direction maybe
they'll they'll still do the open World
stuff but they're going to add something
to
it pretty sure that's what the what
they're going for is there any no I
don't have anything close I can warp
too just going to have to walk all this
way way but it gives me some time to
read the
chat you're one of only two people I'll
stop anything to watch live oh thank you
that that means a lot I don't really
consider my streams to be all that
entertaining but
that's I don't think highly of myself
that way because I I I'm not a
speedrunner I'm I suck at video games in
general but uh yeah if you're having fun
then I'm having fun
too yeah Anthony says I'm more curious
about the next console to be honest like
I feel Nintendo has always had crazy
Innovation on the console
front yeah yeah I'm curious too I just
don't really watch uh switch 2 videos
that often cuz I think uh they're a bit
too speculative and they're not really
based on anything except rumors
mostly they're they're usually not all
of them of course some of them are just
reporting what what what comes out but
by God if some of them aren't very click
baity it just annoys
me like they'll just have a extremely
clickbait title and then just in small
like parentheses at the end rumor it's
like yeah well you probably should have
started with that because now everyone
thinks first of all the title doesn't
always fit all the way on the screen and
you know
that have you played links Awakening
yeah yeah all of them actually the
original the the DX version and the uh
the
Remake hey a
cave let's follow wait uh-oh
oh that was the wrong one still turning
black I don't know
why oh he he
de actually I can get on top of this
mountain this
way
uhoh uh no that's not what I want sorry
I'm still getting to grips with the
controls
again
uh let's go with the
hoe
o I got to fuse some weapons together
soon thank you Dorito queen that means a
lot did you have any questions or things
you wanted answers to
or not that you have to
but let's see what Treasures await us oh
I like
like uh I think I can recall
this
oh oh you got to recall the last
one and then break his
shell is it quiet well maybe the game
play is quiet I purposely put it on
quiet because I'm mostly talking to
people uh do I still have recall
no what why are you telling me to do
amiibo stuff let let let me play the
game I think my controller is acting up
a little bit hold
on
okay
ow that was not a good
idea the first death
in I think the whole playthrough and
it's because of a like like maybe I did
die before I just don't
remember Anthony says I suck at Play
video
games well it kind of depends what kind
of video game in in general like I'm a
very slow learner when it comes to any
video
game like I'm playing uh escape from
tarov right now and that that game is
brutal for beginners on let me
no okay I'm just I'm just going to get
out of
here trying to get the Zord is the
main second death overall okay thanks
for keeping count cuz I I sure as H
don't
uh oh just uh showing support well thank
you so much again Dorito queen that
means a
lot do you have any theories on Link's
Awakening uh yeah yeah I
think but maybe that that one has
already been covered but one Theory I
once considered was
that uh the reason why Co in island is
in trouble is because of link not not
because of Any pre-existing dangers it's
like link brings his nightmare into that
dream
world CU at the end the
nightmares they manifest from link
from Link's body at the end right before
the final boss
fight and one of them takes on the shape
of Ganon which makes sense if that's
like his biggest
fear I have to cook up some stuff
soon I am not well prepared at
all oh I can hit a ride up
there
God there's so many enemies
here yeah that that that was a theory I
once considered working on but I think
someone already did something very very
similar don't remember who it was
but hey gossip guys yeah I'm always
enjoying
playing and
just you know
just having
fun CU even though this whole
playthrough is kind of like a a setup
for my video about how terrible the
story of this game is uh like that's
just one aspect to it so the game play
is still
fun so I'm definitely having
fun I still have to watch your latest
video by the way I haven't seen it yet
I've I've been kind of busy with other
stuff do I consider making a sequel to
Life as a bobblin um perhaps at some
point if I have a good
idea I've been asked this question quite
a lot of times but yeah I I'm not really
the type to do the same thing twice just
because because of views or anything
like
that if I do another one I want it to be
at least just as good and
original plus like uh the first one was
kind of made under circumstances where
where I I kind of had to wait for this
game to come out so I had time to do
other crazy funny things but as this
game's launch Drew closer I had little
to no time to do that kind of stuff cuz
obviously you're doing theories on new
trailers and new teasers
and you know that's where most people
are including myself are going to be
looking at the
most Dutch Dutch bobson says
out
a little bit of Dutch for you uh I think
we can can we go straight to sidon I'm
not
sure or do I have to talk to Yona first
I'll just talk to Yona first why not
we're here
anyway
hello my bro wanted to know what your
favorite dungeon in the link to the past
and your favorite item in AR of time
are Link to the Past
uh let me
think I kind of like the the atmosphere
of the Desert Palace the misery m is
pretty
cool
uh I hate Skull Woods even though I like
the concept I just find it very
confusing oh there she
is
and my favorite item in aine of time is
uh in terms of Aesthetics the mirror
Shield because it just looks
awesome but in terms of
[Music]
functionality I guess the long
shot lens of Truth is also cool yeah
just the the the concept is cool yeah
the hook shot is so it's so iconic kind
of made me wish it was in this game as
well can you imagine if we were able to
hook shot on things to get some extra
like get an extra
boost you can clean the statue and fix
the mural without talking to anyone it
makes the MPC look stupid
you can use Splash fruits right I think
I did it a different way last time uh on
my first playthrough that is I used one
of those W water
spouts not a splash
fruit but I don't have any Splash fruit
I think oh wait I do I do I I have
three
[Music]
uh h
that's
it look at that handsome
man it's kind of funny how they removed
the memorial to mea's
death in favor well they gave it a nicer
place up on the hill though on up on the
mountain
wait I was talking about link I don't
know who you were talking
about yes
yes it's funny how this part they do
remember you they did memorialize what
you did in bre to
Wild
anyone missed the trailer analysis well
we'll probably be doing that again when
the new Zelda game starts getting
teased Senor Divine Beast
hello so one little thing I won't be
streaming as long as I did last two
times which was almost 4 hours because I
do have a little bit of a headache just
uh I think I need a new pillow or
something I woke up with a headache and
I'm it's been bugging me the whole day
have you played Super Mario Brothers
Wonder not yet not yet it's still on my
to-do list same as um Super Mario
RPG we replace the statue of your
romantic interest with a statue of your
bro ship with the prince
yeah
she comes from a different domain right
they say so where would that
be this song is funny hearing this song
because my fiance keeps using it in her
crafting videos I think she just
uploaded a new one and it has this song
in it as well so when I hear this song I
think of her instead of this game
wherever Cass is now probably oh yeah
maybe that's what the new Zelda is going
to be about they're going to visit a new
continent after you met with sidon
perhaps you could visit me at the
infirmary on the floor above
yeah
sure uh Senor Divine Beast says I think
the statue moving makes sense the have
have to kind of move past the events of
the Calamity but I but still remember
her at mea Park yeah yeah yeah
absolutely uh what is the fastest way up
pyus Mountain which I've been calling
polyus Mountain for the longest time
uh I don't have aora armor and I don't
have money for aora armor so we're just
going to have have to
climb do I have
Springs
no I do not have
Springs but I do have a fan which I can
use pen was the only character that
mentioned Cass yeah we met we talked
about that last week yeah he's the only
one not even his own wife and children
mention
him don't you just need some
fish I don't
know pen isn't a good replacement for C
I think it's also just pen doesn't have
that big of a role in this story overall
like yeah he goes after the rumors which
are not all that
interesting All Things
Considered
uh do I
have
anything do I have Flint yeah I do have
Flint why do I keep keep getting tips
even
now
uh oh I I didn't need Flint damn
it it's no revali's Gale
but it's get gets pretty
close
charger gamer says
uh did you know the Zora family
connection is actually the strongest
rout the Champions at least at the end
of bre wild Zelda says they should visit
the domain to support King DOR fan yeah
I think the best uh like relationship
between the hens and the Zora you
mean like in general the the the all the
four races seem to be much more
connected to each other or five I should
say like even a
gudo who have historically been kind of
like on their
own I think the Z are probably the most
distant in this game
though especially in breath of the wild
not not so much
here but they don't they they're kind of
Pride too too prideful to ask for
help uh I think I do have to get past it
oh
God I don't want to fight wh rope
they're they're the
worst
the Zai are dead yeah
apparently from what I
understand something about the Japanese
translation says that they died out or
something I still don't really buy it
but oh come
on come on
yes muu is like that yeah well in the in
breath of wild all of all of the older
Zoras were they were kind of like the
stuck
up old guys who just didn't want
to know anything about the high and
still blame them for everything that
happened during the the Calamity and
stuff but in this game they're they're a
lot
better can I can I can I
please
nope you know what I'm just going to
do another ravali
Gale
uh I can make
that
how do you feel about the theory that
tears of the Kingdom breath the wild
take place in an alternate timeline in
Skyward Sword where link fights Dem
mise well it kind of depends on how that
works I I just have a hard time
accepting the idea that Ganondorf shows
up before Dem mise or around the same
time as Dem mise
because isn't that like the whole point
of the curse is that that's where it
started
man we are getting crafty here getting
to all these
places like that that's one of the
biggest reasons why I feel
like the whole idea that like these
games have to take place at the very end
right if they want to keep consistency
at least which I'm not sure if they will
at this
point they kind of showed that they
don't really care all that
much put five bundles of wood and one
cone and F light it up you'll get even
more height yeah but I I only have one
left so but I did not know that you get
even more of a boost that way it's a
cool mechanic
though I don't think I used the the pine
cones one single time during my first
playthrough I had no idea what they
did but now I'm a smarter
man Nintendo is not known for
consistency no not
really can I recall this
yeah
well they are consistent in terms of
quality one of the most consistent
developers in the world probably at this
point there he
is some people say the Zone I founding
is not the first founding but it's
because the goddess statues fell from
skyl into the Forgotten
Temple uh we can't see see it in the
past cutcenes I'm not sure good to see
you my
friend it's good to see you my
friend
yeah sidon has probably has the best
theme although I also really liked the
ruk's theme in bre the wild a
lot which I think only shows up in the
fire temple briefly in the fire temple
music this part
is always kind of funny to
me where it's like
uh I'm wondering if the sludge could be
the source or if the source of the
sludge could be coming from the floating
islands it's like well you can just look
up and see that it's falling from the
floating
islands you don't have to wonder it's
pretty much
confirmed
a says I just can't take the English
voice acting in this game
seriously I think it's okay I think it's
better in this game than it was in
breath the wild for
sure I didn't play the Japanese version
myself if I actually understood Japanese
I would have
but yeah that's not going to happen
anytime
soon the sludge kind of reminds me of
Mario
sunshine it's like oh could that could
that be the source
uh
well I don't know
man uh so I have to go to muu
right
uh oh
jto at Toto Lake May yield some
information I think he's over there let
me
just activate this
one
goop Mario Sunshine is underr
I don't know if it's underrated but I it
is one of my favorite Marios cuz I love
summer I love everything about
it uh yeah I think it's that
way let's go activate the tower as well
I think Toto lake is on the way
there it's like over there
I'm not doing shrines at least not in
this current like if I do shrines I'll
probably do them off screen
because they they actually make me have
to
think and I'm terrible at thinking and
Mining chat so I'll just be quiet for
the whole for the whole
stream oh that's funny like last stream
someone says Tulin was the worst the
worst of the
companion or at least that they didn't
care for him something like
that uh yeah that's I think that's
him
good oh no that's not
GTO gato
Jato Kieran Buckley was that you who
said you were not a big Tulin fan last
last stream as
well Tulin was foreshadowed in age of
Calamity DLC yeah he sure was
although he was creepy as hell in that
game for some
reason like the way he laughs and smiles
at the end it's it's so
uncanny oh there he
is I have to fix this whole
thing uh I don't want
to
I think you can just do it right you
don't have to
talk and do like you don't have to do
all this right you can just shoot the
arrow or does it does it not
work uh
is it not here around here
somewhere wait what I I have to actually
pay
attention in the
mud
okay it's not in this
right in the
sludge I don't remember where it
is let's do the tower first real quick
and then I'll come
back uh yeah let's do that
first yeah yeah I'll I'll I'll do the
I'll do the thing after I do the tower
yeah it is close to the cave okay cool
cool I just want to have the
map makes things a lot
easier toolin ability is probably my
favorite or at least the one I use the
most I just got 1,000 cororo seeds after
8 months you are
crazy you're not supposed to do that
Nintendo Nintendo is actively mocking
you for doing
it that's actually a great achievement
though
but it's not for
me I like re you but she doesn't really
have much of an arc to me like cool she
learned to be a better leader I guess
yeah I I feel like she was already a
better
leader that was already kind of her Arc
in breath of the wild wasn't it like she
was way too young and she had all this
weight put on her shoulders and by the
end she realizes that she'll just have
to be a better leader and I guess it's
just the same thing
here
but to be fair none of the sages really
have like the modern day sages
have really like big character
development or anything like
that outside of their Regional phenomena
they don't really do
much that's that's one thing that's so
frustrating about the way tears of the
Kingdom handles its storytelling you
know
I I really got so attached to the
characters in like
uh what was it oh wait uh like in
Twilight Princess for example you have
all these characters that you really
start to care
for I don't really care much outside of
like Lincoln
Zelda uh
yes puzzle
solved
man that was a hard
puzzle I just want link to have facial
expressions
again yeah I
agree like in Wind
Waker like that that's one moment that
kind
of ruined the whole Zelda dragon
dronification
reveal like link does not react to it at
all like in terms like emotionally he he
does not seem to
care and then I think back to Skyward
Sword how angry link gets at some moment
or how depressed he gets and it's like
yeah like link actually felt like a
character there and to you know to be
fair this link does have his his charms
here and there but I just don't
understand why they chose to to approach
him that way after Skyward
Sword yeah link is just
like yeah we talked about that on on the
last stream link doesn't tell anyone
about Zelda's dronification except impa
and impa doesn't tell anyone
either nor does her assistant because
she does have someone with her one of
the
guards one one of the guards that
normally
stands in front of her
house we got the
map is Triforce Heroes considered a
Mainline Zelda game yeah
yes every
usually you can tell if it has the
legend of prefix it's usually considered
a Canon timeline quote unquote timeline
Zelda
game with the exception of links uh uh
uh the Zelda 2 The Adventure of Link
that's the only exception
uhoh which is why the age of Calamity
and uh the other
one the hu Warrior games link links
crossbow training tingles Rosie whatever
rupy land those are not considered
Cannon and the CDI games of course but
that goes without saying it's not even
from the same
developer the only expression that
doesn't look goofy uh in this l his face
of
pain and he does get hurt quite a
lot so it's like oh it's right there
yeah you're you were
right it's literally like right around
the
corner
uh Splash
fruit
prepare for frame
drops there we
go it's stupid that age of Calamity is
not considered Canon because this game's
present day sages were in age of
Calamity well yeah it's like an
alternate timeline kind of deal
uh it's not entirely clear if it if it
is this side on from this timeline or if
it's like another scon from a timeline
where like age of calamity's future so
to speak before it was changed by Tero I
I'm I'm not too sure but yeah it doesn't
work because obviously sidon would have
remembered that whole trip to the
Past fighting the Calamity and all that
stuff but the fact that they they don't
even address it in this game proves that
it wasn't it wasn't Canon before we kind
of had to guess like yeah maybe Nintendo
will pull a 180 on us an UNO reversa
card and uh will just suddenly say like
nope it's Canon and they're suddenly
going to acknowledge it all the events
that happened in age of Calamity in this
game
but the only the only thing I did not
like about age of Calamity is that
nobody there's not that many
consequences to what
happens I don't think a single person
dies in that whole game which you know
it's a game about the
Calamity even the king
survives but you know that's why it's an
alternate
timeline yeah Suga was probably the best
thing to come out of age of Calamity in
in my humble opinion he was super cool
he should have been in this game too cuz
there should be a version of him in this
one or at least they could still do
that is there a Zelda dungeon you like
but the community
hates um I guess the water temple from
arine of
time
uh other than that I cannot really like
the Z Community doesn't really hate all
that much when it comes to
dungeons like where people are actually
like hating on it with a with a fiery
passion wait did I have to actually read
that thing or did I just screw
myself
uh
oh yeah yeah okay okay I he did decipher
it
h actually I do I really have to speak
to King Doran I know what I'm supposed
to do
right although I don't remember exactly
where the droplet thingy was but I think
I can probably see on the map
uh I
it's somewhere like in this general area
I'm pretty sure actually I can just warp
here smart gamer says for me it's jabu
jabu's belly why do people dislike that
one the inside of a fish may be gross it
is but it's Unique no other game does it
yeah it reminded me of
Pinocchio where he goes into the belly
of a
whale I liked it it's
different albe it a little
gross oh yeah he gives you the king
scale yeah that's
true
uh pretty sure seidon has nothing new to
tell me hey
hey so if I had
already I'm actually Cur curious if I
had all the memories right now all of
Zelda's
memories would link react probably not I
should try that I should I should do a
new playthrough on a new file at some
point and just get all the memories like
that's the first thing I do after
getting back
from uh after getting back from the
great sky
island and then just talk to everyone
and I'm pretty sure everyone will just
be oh
well I wonder where Zelda
is yeah they didn't they didn't account
for that for I'm pretty
sure I do remember where I don't
remember where the king is but I do
remember kind of he's in one of those
waterfalls
here anyone remember
meow
I dread the Twilight Twilight Palace
yeah the hands yeah yeah that's
an anxiety inducing for
sure like I'm pretty sure he's right
down here in this down this
hole right yeah there he
is mind if I drop
in
he remembers
me yeah I just find him instantly that
was pure
luck
Doran
like he for sure is the most like
affected by this whole sludge all the
other Zoras are just like H mild
inconvenience hey mind if I drop
it
yeah muu just goes back to being
grumpy
he remains a trusted friend of the Zoro
I would hope so I I saved the world last
game I saved your domain from flooding
and I saved the entire Kingdom in
general how dare you
sir we encountered Princess Zelda just
after hyro Castle uh ascended into the
sky floating islands appeared as if from
nowhere see so the islands were never
visible before that for some reason muu
gets fired he should get
fired Athens says an underrated dungeon
for me would be the city in the sky is
the city in the guy considered
underrated I thought that was like a fan
favorite I I definitely think it's
amazing uh the Double CL shots marked
the debut of the real spider link spider
link
spider yeah I
agree the sense of height and and
and just the way you Traverse that
dungeon it's it's amazing
which would not work as well in this
game because you're so mobile and you
have your paraglider you don't really
have to fear
much according to your story Princess
Zelda disappeared suddenly in the depths
below hu Castle on the other hand she
suddenly appeared near Zora's domain and
Unleashed a monster Upon
Us
yeah
how do people not figure this
out before you
do and even princess out it may well be
the answer to the riddles that can be
only be found Skyward Skyward
Sword uh smart gamer says sometimes I
wonder why don't we see who grubs as a
race anymore they have not been in
modern games they were cool and
termina uh
yeah are they not in other games at
all trying to think for sure they're in
Minish
Cap in in some of the 2D games
but
take a
few perhaps the time is nearing for me
to pass the title to
King title of King to
sidon yeah that would probably be a good
idea after 200
years
I mean clearly he was a good ruler if
you can keep the kingdom running for 200
years all
right maybe link doesn't really like
Zelda all that much that's why he
doesn't tell anybody yeah maybe that's
the
problem it's like yeah I never trusted
her to begin with she there was always
something off about
her I would love to see how some of the
older dungeons would play with Link's
new abilities yeah I I I was very
curious to see that too but they didn't
do
that I guess the the fire temple came
the closest maybe or maybe the lightning
Temple
did but you can cheese the fire dungeon
so easily if you have Z like zonai
devices
just break that dungeon completely you
just buy a or get a super spring and
you're
good uh Darkness 321 says are you
familiar with the channel the
basement no what is it about what what
do they
do
yeah lightning lightning Temple is Al is
also my favorite at least in terms of
Aesthetics for
sure I'm sure we can locate the land of
the skyish it will lead us to the
floating
oh
GE I have to do
everything there it is that's a fish
isn't
it I would say
so it's that
one do I actually have
to your objectiv align with sidon if you
find a clue about the watery Bridge
collecting to
blah blah blah
blah oh yeah yeah yeah okay so I do
this and then he
will the the the Waterworks are probably
the most awesome part of this whole
Quest and the music there is really
great
too
who should probably do
just balloon
away come on come on come on
yeah should probably use a different
weapon for
this to be fair I didn't really like
Master mode all that much in in breath
the wild to be completely
honest uhoh I don't know if I'm going to
make
this probably not weo come
on I don't think I have the stamina for
this we'll see whatever happens
happens
uh merillo says hi just got my tears of
the Kingdom tattoo what did you have as
a
tattoo also Darkness uh let me
see they do mainly Zelda stuff and made
a great song called mea did you
know
well I'm just going to I'm just going to
die isn't that the island where the Z
home is uh so that's three
deaths and I was I was reading chat so I
didn't even realize I was running out of
stamina I should probably up upgrade my
uh my zone ey devices shouldn't
I like Massa mode felt kind of cheap to
me cuz the because of the whole
regeneration
like it just makes enemies it doesn't
make them smarter it doesn't give them
new attacks or new abilities or better
AI it just it's just more
HP more HP and
they they just become even more of a
bullet sponge than they they were
before I've never it's it's like the
laziest form of challenge to
me and it's not just Zelda it's in like
most games handle it that way and I
don't like it I'm just going to try it
again what if
I take the balloon
up do I still have yeah I
do what if I just put this
here set fire to it and then use a pine
cone
as soon as I almost run out I'm just
going
to throw the pine Con
on Boost
upwards see sometimes it's fun it's more
fun to be
limited actually I don't have to do that
that's not big brain at all the balloon
is already working because of the fire
ow
unless it runs out just the balloon
itself runs out if if
it's how does this balloon actually
float the fire is not even underneath
it oh
well if it works it works
right
magic I'm not a smart
man actually the wood bundle just stays
like that it didn't become like a little
campfire did you see that it's a bit
weird don't question
it let's see the droplet should be here
there it
[Music]
is yeah the green skies are the
best
I could have taken the wood oh well I'll
just chop a few trees
down yeah we're doing the water temple
cuz I I believe we did the fire temple
on a different stream one time before I
started this whole like
story story
thing
[Music]
uh I think I just have to go back to
sidon I am not pay pay attention to the
Hut at all yeah ancient Zora Waterworks
is pretty is pretty cool the music is
cool
too it's just empty there's not really a
whole
lot besides that
but I like the atmosphere
something black link says I was so
hoping that the underground part was the
actual Temple yeah yes the actual water
temple
is it's just a floating
island it's not the
greatest yeah the leadup is is pretty
fun before we go to the water temple
itself though after we do the Zora works
I have to quickly make a few
notes or else I'm going to lose track of
this whole story
playthrough I mean it is good for
reference I can just
watch all of this
back if I need
to do you think the water works out the
temple from after enough time uh at this
point I have no
idea
uhoh sludge life
could it be the foul Beast that harmed
father just a like
like let us
fight it's a mighty opponent
all
righty
care give me another one oh my god
really one
shot it is a mighty
foe the like like fight is cool I don't
think it's
cool wow three deaths in one in one
stream and I was doing so
well oh I didn't have full armor
oh normally they they don't one shot you
if you have Full
Hearts
uh can I eat these
yeah like like does not like link that's
a tongue
twister it doesn't save right before the
fight uh I think only if I
save I'm pretty sure if I save right
here then it should start me right
here
I thought this was going to be really
really
easy uh I'll use the
spear I should
probably prepare a couple of
weapons I still have this thing uh I did
not mean to drop that I still have this
thing
uh yeah this is the strongest one I have
this is probably my favorite ability
when it comes to how Dynamic the game
become becomes with this
well I startled
them I don't need that one I do need
this
one
yeah all right senior Divine Beast thank
you for dropping by as
always want to cook that truffle what
the
heck upgrade extreme short
range I'll just use the
spear if I die I have to do this all
over
again yes oh Hardy
truffle
I
gotcha next time I do have a zai cooking
thingy if I die I can just try it over
again I forgot about this fight
completely by the way I didn't even know
this was
part of the the
quest I only remembered the the water
droplet thingy and the
Waterworks all right all
right
we're
just slamming
him no
Tulin
I think he dead oh no
almost see how tuling got in the way
again
see this is where the range comes comes
in Spears are overpowered
yo yeah the music is way better than it
has any right to be cuz it's kind of a
it's not even a mini boss I would
say like likes are very very different
in this in this
game truly a mighty fo well he did one
shot me the last time I even mocked him
for I was like a mighty Foe and then I
just immediately
died that like like defitely had the
first laugh I I had the last laugh
because he didn't even hit me
once
come now come
on he
now
was he just supposed to stand there the
whole
time what do Dutch girls like I don't
know ask them I have no
idea I'm engaged to a Chinese girl so
I'm
uh I'm
clueless
I leave this place to
you off we go link to the pillar of
light
he she does mention mea at
least whoa see so if age of Calamity
would have been Canon he would not be
feeling that way because he went back in
time at least in
his experience and saved her in a
different timeline he but instead he
just feels
horrible cuz he lost
her that's a good
weapon let's go check pay our respects
to me for real
quick well that's what was so cool about
bre of wild is that there were actually
people there was actual actual emotion
there cuz the Champions just they
straight up died there was nothing we
could
do nothing we could do to save
them run hubber says do you think Vortex
he actually died I I'm not in the
position to speculate about that because
I didn't know
her but people who did have told me that
yes I think it was a car accident or
something
but I mean that was before long before
my time as a YouTuber so I had no
relationship to any of those people at
the time the whole chamber of sages
people now I
do but yeah she she was a fellow Dutch
she uh isn't he supposed to be
here
no isn't this where we
meet oh he's uh he's in the
lake uh I have no more pine
cones we'll just
go from rock to rock yeah the tragedy
tragedy it's such an annoying word to
say the
tragedy of breath of wild made it feel
more
real like there were actual consequences
it wasn't like at the end two ghosts
appear and are magically like guess what
you're all alive again everybody's happy
yay no that's a good story also has
sacrifices at
least a story about that kind of subject
matter like the king he
dead cuz that's usually something that
people would
criticize when like at the end it's like
oh the power of friendship saved
everyone
or that's that's always the worst when
people do that when when riters do
that unless it's like for a very
specific
reason
[Music]
uh do you think we'll get a new 2D 2D
Zelda game in the next two or three
years I sure hope so because it's going
to be quite a while before we get a new
3D Zelda
game like the next 3D Zelda game for
sure is going to be at least four or
five years
away
unless they pull a Majora's Mask and
they suddenly have something
new but I don't think
so it's going to be weird though to have
a new a new system with without a Zelda
as a launch title they're probably just
going to Port this game over and it will
look a little bit
better they might not even have to Port
it at all if it runs on the same OS and
everything but it's just more
powerful six years is probably this was
the first time I think it took six years
like normally it's four or
five but you know Co
happened I would love a Mador mask
sequel game
well you cannot really do a sequel to
Majora's Mask unless it takes place like
between Twilight Princess mad's
mask but I think what what makes mad's
mask so awesome is that it's its own
little
thing Aina took took seven years are you
sure there was nothing in between there
no 2D Zelda games
either of course back then 2D Zelda
games were Mainline Zelda games as well
because there were no two there were no
3D Zelda games
yet oh this is G giving me vertigo
like obviously I don't know when they
started development on AR of time
but like the the atmosphere of this
place is pretty
cool you do have to wonder where the the
ambient lighting is coming
from I think I
just why do I keep getting tips about
this did I really just not do anything
before
this uh I don't think I have any bomb
arrows
no oh I have time bombs I can use a time
bomb what what do I have in terms of
Zone I I only have the time
bomb I'm going to use a time bomb
because I'm
lazy
woo yeah the Zora Waterworks should have
been the water temp temp for sure just
makes the most
sense like why would a sky island be a
water
temple it just it just doesn't
work but I guess because of the whole
Sky Island stuff that the sky islands
were already kind of underutilized in
the game like to begin
with so they had to include something
big
uh think I can
just three out of three of the five
temples are in the
sky
uh dragon head is not a dungeon
right or are you referring to the castle
because the castle doesn't really
function as a a dungeon at least not not
in this
game it's just there kind
of uh can can time bombs float I'm
wondering let's find out or I can just
throw
it I have four to spare so
oh did I die
oh no I didn't
die the castle is not in the sky well
kind of but not not as high
up I don't think it falls under the sky
map so yeah very very very close to
death and I still don't have any
food actually I can cook up something
now
because I do have
this uh what else can I add I don't
really have anything without
stats without status effects so I just
have to make
do task failed
successfully yeah
yeah it does disappear doesn't it just
just goes
away
uh add some of
this and some of
this
[Music]
I think that's enough for
now uh oh I don't have to climb
anymore oh no there's more I only have
two time bombs left I
think they want they want you to build a
ladder here I
think that's not
straight
oh yeah I can also could have also used
Reco I always forget I have that
ability oh come
on there we go
Go free for your
lives I'm a genius I I don't really
think so but thank you thank
you are you going to do more shrines
heart's looking pretty low no we're
doing a Pro
run
uh we're doing a super Pro run now at
some point I'm I'm probably going to
just turn on infinite health cuz the
whole point of this is to record Story
related
stuff I'm not here to show off my
non-existent gaming
skills f f for your
lives uh
uh
where where
where that's my entire thought process
where I know there's one in
here but there's no
planks maybe I should do the recall
trick
here
I'm sure there's another way but again
I'm I'm I'm
lazy who did you see that weird
texture
thing think I can make that yeah for
sure come on
maybe
not don't think it's is there any other
way up
here I can just put it down then for
now oh you're supposed to go through
here but again I'm
lazy I'm going to do this the hard way
which is also the easier way
once once it works it's the easier
way okay
okay let's see if this
works just lift it
up and then hold it
there and then bring it
back
let's see
oh yeah oh it's just a chest no I
thought that's where the the plug was
hardcore gamer run no shrines no food no
brain cells
exactly well at least we did the
thing
but yeah you're supposed to go in
here I hate sewer levels you did the
thing uh I think it's over
here
yep but how will I survive
this this does not look safe if I break
this oh come
on
yeah well
we
dead or will the the gate just
open I can I legit cannot imagine how
bad it smells in there well that kind of
depends on how well they ventilate this
area or how much water flow there
is if it's just a stagnant Lake then
probably not too great
hey
goodbye he's so cool about it
too
[Music]
wow that was
anticlimactic you know what I'm just
going to bolt oh wait no he does give me
a chest doesn't
he I secretly want that
chest oh oh oh
oh no okay there we
go there was a mini dungeon in the link
to the past where you had to lower the
water level I think that's this place oh
this
uh it's like the light World version of
the swamp Palace I
think
oh that's
good it's funny how this Shield ended up
not being like important at
all I still think it looks like vati
symbol
too bad it didn't have anything to do
with
vati would have been
cool he would be a great villain to
bring back I
think maybe or maybe just a new villain
maybe it's time
for a just a brand new
villain
imagine I'm imagining bti as a
zai oh yeah
maybe he founded the
zai he created the
zai oh okay we made
it
oh you always keep one on you well it's
not very good unless you put something
on it then it's it's fine but yeah it
looks it looks awesome it's a it's it's
a lot better than the wooden shield from
the from the last game or any other game
in
general it just looks cool
Aster I don't think Aster is coming
back
I mean if if he really is just a hen he
should be dead by this
point cuz he lived around the time of
the Calamity 100 years ago and not
everyone has superpowers where they can
grow up to a thousand years
old I love that the Zonar are just Sky
goat people after all the theory videos
of them being
Barbarian yeah they kind of threw us for
a loop didn't
they I'm I'm even starting to doubt if
the Barbarian armor had anything to do
with the zonai in general maybe it was
just a completely different tribe of
completely different creatures or beings
who lived in faren
because it has nothing to do with the
Zone ey if you look at the actual
clothing and the the decorations on it
there there's nothing that points to the
Zone
ey like the belt buckle is a completely
different symbol the general style of
clothing is very
different no one has the power to grow
to up to a thousand years old unless
you're aora I think Ganondorf does
too because of the Triforce of power and
all that
stuff or maybe demise his curse
or cuz he's like looking really really
good in Twilight Princess and Wind Waker
and he's supposed to be like over a
hundred years old at that
point well over 100 years old cuz I
think he was
already like in his in his 30s or 40s in
enough
time and Wind Waker and Twilight
Princess are supposed to be like one or
200 years after the fact I
think I think they say around
100 yeah this gondorf didn't have the
Triforce of power that's true but he was
preserved he did have the secret
Stone maybe that does something similar
I have to get the armor
first
a
really canot just give me a ride
up freaking s
on
I didn't I did not activate the shrine
here I'll just fly from the
tower then why did Zelda need to eat
hers I'm not
sure well it could be that raru seal
preserved gondorf in in some way and not
necessarily gandor himself I'm not not
sure
the kind of conf confused on the whole
lore in that sense in
general it's why I haven't made that
many videos about
it I think after my
big story critique video I'm going to be
done with uh tears of the Kingdom for a
while at
least like obviously if I find something
interesting to talk about I will but
it's not going to be a main
focus
I don't really feel like talking about
the timeline
or trying to explain how these games
follow up on it which is a shame because
some people have been looking forward to
the evolution of Hyrule part five and I
was too but now I'm starting to doubt if
it's even worth doing it
because we don't even know which
timeline Branch it follows up on I can
make a more speculative video I
guess
one where it's a little less
sciency and just trying to make because
it's so difficult to make sense of how
the how that would even work like
suppose it's people keep like throwing
the whole Dragon break thingy like the
the timelines merged
somehow it's like okay cool but how
would that
work like what caused it
to First of all what caused it to merge
in the first place and what kind of
consequences would there
be yeah it is an it was a fun series to
do as well I really like working on the
evolution of
Hyrule and I really want to do a final
one to wrap it up or at least final
until we get the next Zelda
game but right now I'm kind of
struggling to find out how that would
all fit together we don't even know if
this is the same continent as the old
hyru was or if it's like a completely
new continent
or cuz they kind of imply or
suggest that the
uh you know the whole world was
destroyed or something or hyu at least
was destroyed and then refounded by the
zonai but there had to be still people
living here in
Hyrule like Sonia's people were already
on the surface when the zai arrived by
my
guess jaw says coming to say hello
hello to the
Infirmary
can I can I yes
woohoo this could be the Fallen timeline
of the Fallen
timeline
yeah actually where is the infirmary is
that on this
level that's not the infirmary but there
are things
here
give me those oh
crib oh it is above
okay God bless a
send is it
here or is it the uh
uh King's throne room
now oh I forgot about the monument
here what does it say
again
[Music]
blah renovating the Zora Stone monuments
that had fallen to ruin what why did
they fall to ruin we could read them in
the previous game
right he just rewrote history and just
made up an excuse oh they got damaged
during the Calamity yeah that's totally
what happened
anyway let me tell you about my heroic
stories oh it was the the
king
uh yeah okay okay okay I got it
but I
remember oh I need to talk to
her still recuperating a
laruta la
laruta
just
here
no I'm confused
now I really don't remember much of this
part of the game at
all
any any
tips so I don't have waste more time
because I do have to stop streaming soon
I'm
honestly a little
tired the whole Chik Tech Vanishing was
so hecking weird to me yeah that makes
two of
us the only way it can make sense of
it make sense of it is if Tero had
something to do with it I don't think
Tero is
Cannon where where was the
infirmary sidon is up
here is she still at mea's cord
[Music]
uh even aan can climb up waterfalls by
wearing Zoro armor which Yona task
herself with
repairing would be nice if they actually
told you where Yona is maybe sidon did
and I wasn't paying attention it's
probably my my own fault because
I'm only half paying
attention sir are you repairing the the
armor thingy you have a hammer and a
thingy she's attempting to repair your
Zora armor oh of course she just talk to
people like like you always
do you know full what full well that the
Zora armor allows even a Highland like
you to climb waterfalls it is essential
if you hope to travel these parts with
ease oh okay yeah you were
right meus
cord yeah I also haven't played the
actual Story part of this since my first
play through which may early
June
it's been a
while it's actually kind of crazy how
the game is going to be almost a year
old in a few
months it's
nuts is she up there or is she down here
she's oh there she
is she Blended in with the
sludge
I talked to these old Zora and Brew they
hated linoln Highlands yeah they sure
did even after 100
years can you imagine that doing
something like making an honest mistake
or whatever and then 100 years later
people still get on to you for
it I guess it kind of depends on how
serious that mistake would be but
uh wait what did let's check the
log it does require one more thing I
need a fish called an ancient ar oh yeah
okay I know where to get
those you haven't seen them around
lately that's because it's it's a
completely new species they live on the
sky islands
right I'll just go to the great Sky
Island
I'm sure that they are
there plenty of
water go to this
one I don't know losing Meo was one of
more than an honest mistake for the
Zoras well I mean it was that their
choice to send her into
battle everyone uh like every one of the
races banded together to face something
unknown and the Zoras are the only ones
were like oh the hens should have known
better they were they assured us victory
was what's
coming I mean I get that they're
emotional about it but come on
man link wasn't even the one who made
the decisions he's not he's not a
king he's just a
soldier uh there should be fish here
somewhere
those tiny little ponds usually have
them sa sacrifices had to be made
yeah sometimes when you go to war you
don't always know if you're going to
win luckily the the zoron the the zoron
the gorons are pretty pretty chill about
it like yeah we erected a giant statue
of his face and now we're all
happy did you not fish for
one what do you
mean to the cooking pot
I cannot swim that that far with this
stamina I I guess I can just go to the
other Shrine there's all kinds of Pawns
over
here oh there's there're in this in mea
statues mea statues
Lake
okay then I'll go
there man those fish fell a long way
then if they're all the way over
there they fell thousands of feet
down and
survived I told you two minutes ago I
wasn't paying attention
okay
story of my
life when I look at chat I'm I'm playing
terribly when I'm playing
terribly or when I'm looking at chat i'
play terribly I should
say and when I'm playing
decently then I cannot look at
chat if you fall into water you you'll
be fine yeah that's not how it works
it's like
[Music]
concrete at some height it's just you
might as well just be hitting the
pavement unless you're one of those Rock
divers who know exactly how to
uh how to position their bodies to
minimize the risk but even then you you
risk breaking legs and
[Music]
ligaments
yes if you locate one please bring bring
one to me I just
did oh here you
go you'll be flattened like a pancake
yeah water temple is by far the worst
one I agree it's very short
too it's just like three main floating
Islands do you live in Amsterdam no I
live near Rotterdam not in rdam but
close to
it the Harbor City of
rdam worse than the spirit Temple well
the spirit Temple is I wouldn't even
call that a dungeon to be honest I
didn't even realize that was a
dungeon technically the spirit Temple
itself is not even a dungeon it's the
the robot Factory thingy
uh the construct
Factory the spirit Temple is just like
you walk in you do some robot
Robo
Wars whatever and then it's uh then it's
done the spirit Temple just reminds me
of arms
yeah that's how the fight kind of feels
like doesn't
it Rock them sockum robots what is that
from is that a
game I know the name and i' I've even
used it a couple of
times but is that like was that a show
or a game
or and why do I know that that name I I
probably just heard it vicariously but
still they must have been pretty big if
everyone knows that term oh they're toys
ah they were kind of like transforming I
guess oh bye
Darkness I will check out that channel
you
recommended I always like discovering
new Zelda
channels Let Me swim
upwards no Tulin you
what what's happening I'm
stuck tul
it I just blaming tul it like for
everything I was literally stuck there
uhoh
yeah
no I'm blaming Tulin on like for
everything look he
keeps you're supposed to press a right
when you hit the
waterfall but he keeps doing his we
woo oh I'm not wearing the armor oh my
God I'm such an
idiot
oh I really hope NE oh he's still he
still used did he almost blew me through
the
waterfall Wee
Woo oh I'm getting there I'm getting to
that
point oh yeah it's still quite a long
way up uh actually I am going to end the
stream
soon yeah that's tula's fault too he
should have told me to to put on the
armor
oh you don't have to press a anymore
okay I don't believe
you there he
is my
man my body feels light as a feather the
first time I saw that the like low
gravity stuff I thought oh those those
islands must be so high up that you're
getting to like the edge of space but no
it's just it's just random for some
islands some islands have it some some
islands don't even the ones who are
lower in altitude some of them have the
the low gravity cheat on I
guess [__] shitty
yeah and like underwater exploration
would be pretty
cool oh
no yeah that was kind of a missed
opportunity I
guess
it's kind of been the name of the game
to be honest like a lot of potential
that
was they like
wasted also a lot of stuff they did
right of
course but they could have done
more
but yeah I am probably going to end the
stream in about two
minutes or else my headache is going to
get
worse my thalassophobia could never go
in the water I'm
sorry not after subnotica
what is theophobia is that just fear of
not seeing the bottom or
something I still have to play subnotica
I it sounds like a the type of game for
me
because it's exploration it's open world
and it it also has a lot of
lore you can find at least according to
my brother I don't know if he's lying to
me just to get me to play
it my brother just told me he got
addicted to genin impact I was like no
not breath of the
wuss I will probably never play Gin
impact I already know
that only the first one
was really good right the other
one uh like something
zero subnotica subzero or below zero or
whatever I heard that one wasn't as good
as the
first but I should probably start with
the first
one but yeah I'm I would be happy to
give it a try but first I have to finish
Outer Outer worlds
below zero yeah
okay yeah my
brother he gave into the
whole genin impact
thingy yeah below zero is the sequel
okay I didn't know if it was DLC or like
uh soft like one .5
or but it like this the review scores
were not as high as the original I think
maybe it's still good I don't
know I'm hearing the we woo in my sleep
yeah it's the most played sound effect
aside from Link's footsteps
probably give me the zonai
devices uh do I actually have oh yeah
not that
much nice nice Dodge over that thrown
rock I can assure you that was not on
purpose
stabilizer
battery zonoid
devices I can do a couple more I I
usually don't use these cores
anyway
for my fireworks video I had to I have I
had to find Rockets I think or at least
one specific part and it just I could
not find them it just so was so
annoying
[Music]
uh
yeah actually we reached the shrine I
think this would be a good place to uh
this will
just shoot it right
yeah do you guys like the shrine
structure I will just stand over here in
in the safety of the shrine
and give me my final words we actually I
took a few notes not that
many Demon King secret
Stone yeah I'm not a huge fan of the
shrines to be honest i' I'd rather have
more traditional dungeons or quote
unquote traditional of course they can
put it into a new format but I'd rather
have like 10 B big big dungeons that are
just out there for you to find
then like a 100 of these tiny micro
dungeons I know it it's some people like
it some people who have don't have a lot
of time to play games they like just
doing a couple of shrines and then
moving on with their life but not me
that's it's not for me I prefer the
bigger
stuff
yeah for one game it's it was a I always
appreciate when they try new things but
Tis of the kingdom is already so
derivative as is so having the shrines
again having the cororo seeds again
having so many things being
rehashed I think the next game does have
to do things very very differently yeah
like even 20 like midsize dungeons would
already be more cool
for
sure but it's a personal
preference like one of my favorite
things about the Zelda series is
dungeons like dungeon crawling that's
what made me fall in love with arine of
time the first
time just stepping into these places and
not knowing what what's going to be
there and was challenging at least for
my 12-year-old
self yeah and it also kind of yeah for
the for the sake of variation I I agree
with that
too hey Sparks
Aus hi to you
too yeah I'm doing well I just have a
very very slight headache which has been
nagging me all day so I'm going going to
head to bed early
probably so I'm going to end the stream
a little earlier than normal but we'll
do another one on Wednesday and then
again next weekend so we have two
streams per week now at least until my
video is
done yeah it's like one of those
headaches that is it's
just too it's not like big enough to
take an aspin for it because I don't
like taking meds in
general so it's like still below that
threshold where you're like oh this is
so painful I have to take a painkiller
but it just it ah it just nags at you it
just hovers over you like your head is
in a bit of a cloud it's very annoying
but you know it is what it is it'll go
away I just have to get a good night's
sleep and then I'll be
fine and then I think for the next
stream before we actually start doing
anything I really have to go over my
notes with you guys I didn't want to do
it again this time but keep holding it
off but I actually want to make a bit of
a like an overview of the story of how
it unfolds who knows what so maybe this
Wednesday we can for example take a look
at
raru see what he knows and what he isn't
telling link which he should be telling
link like all the stuff that he knows he
knows Ganondorf he knows the secret
Stones how they work he knows all kinds
of stuff which he doesn't share with you
before he disappears and doesn't appear
reappear until the end so let's do that
next stream maybe I can create kind of
like a an overview or graph or whatever
so something to like hold on to while
I'm writing my script because there's so
many characters doing different things
and I kind of have to keep track I I
want to make sure that when I criticize
the story I'm not saying something like
oh this person doesn't like nobody
reacts to this uh uh this piece of
knowledge and meanwhile there is because
then that's what people are going to be
hyperfocusing on I want to make
sure like absolutely sure that uh I I
get as much right as humanly possible
obviously there's going to be small
oversights and mistakes that's just how
it is or else this video is going to
take a year to complete and then my
channel will for sure
die because I'm not pulling in millions
of
views uh
but you know yeah we can put a graph
together or
something and then just look at who
knows what because there's usually
people here who played it more recently
and they are it's a bit more fresh in
their memory than it is in
mine so that will be uh that will be
cool
but yeah thank you uh I hope it's not a
tumor no it's probably
not I think that would probably give you
more of a headache than than
this but yeah uh thank you all so much
for joining and for dropping by as
always it's always very very much
appreciated and uh yeah you also get
some rest
at least you
Europeans and I will see you next time
bye-bye